>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Fenella France: Good afternoon.
I'm Fenella France, Chief
of the Preservation Research
and Testing Division, and
I'd like to welcome you today
to a [inaudible] lecture on Medieval
Medicine for Modern Infections.
Could Ancientbiotics
help in the fight
against antimicrobial resistance?
I'd like to introduce
our speaker today,
Dr. Erin Connelly who's the
[inaudible] fellow for data curation
and medieval studies [inaudible]
Institute for manuscript studies
and the [inaudible] and manuscripts.
She holds a Ph.D. in Medieval
English from the University
of Nottingham and her doctoral
[inaudible] was a first edition
of the middle English translation
of [inaudible] a significant
medieval medical text.
She also holds a BC in biology
and worked briefly in
molecular oncology.
She's part of the Ancientbiotics
team which explores the relevance
of medieval medicines
for modern infections.
I know you're going to find
this absolutely fascinating,
and I'm going to hand over to Erin.
[ Applause ]
>> Erin Connelly: Thank you very
much to Fenella and to everyone here
at the Library of Congress for
inviting me to speak today.
I am very much looking forward to
sharing this research with you.
So we have a few objectives
for today's talk.
In summary, the Ancientbiotics
team tests the efficacy
of medieval medicines
for modern infections.
And I'm going to be talking
about a successful pilot study
on a 1000-year-old recipe
known as Bald's Eyesalve,
which turned out to be a potent
anti-staphylococcal agent.
Its repeatedly killed Staph
aureus biofilms in vitro
and it killed methicillin
resistant Staph aureus or MRSA
in a mouse chronic wound model.
Now because this pilot
study occurred in 2015,
we'll also be talking about current
and future research plans
of which there are many.
Now, I'm going to be
presenting scientific evidence
from the pilot study, but I speak
to you today as a medievalist
and although this research
does hold implications
for present day drug discovery.
It also raises very interesting
questions about the methodology
of medieval practitioners.
And for a long time,
the middle ages,
medieval medicine has been dismissed
as irrelvant, overly superstitious,
a time of gathering
information solely
to gather together information.
We're all familiar with the term
dark ages, labeling the period
as unenlightened by
science or reason.
However, recent scholarship may
show that there is more methodology
to the medicines of
medieval practitioners
and further inquiry may show
that their medicines were more
than just placebos
or palliative aids
but actual antibiotics being
used long before the advent
of modern infection control.
So as a medievalist, I
thought it best begin
with a story from medical history.
What you see on your
screen is an excerpt
from Thomas Gale's Certaie
Workes of Chirurgerie.
Now, Thomas Gale was
a 16th century master
of the London Barber Surgeon's
Guild, and he's connected
with the [inaudible] of
one of the text studied
by the Ancientbiotics team.
Fenella mentioned it's known
as the lilly of medicines.
In the foleo preceding this except,
Thomas Gale relates a personal case
study of a young boy with sore eyes.
He says, "Every member of the guild
is working on treating this child.
They try all their treatments,
but it only brings the
child's condition to worse."
Until Gale says, "We left the
child to the work of nature."
However, the child's mother
found a recipe in an old book,
brought this recipe to
Gale who distilled it,
applied it to the child and as
you see underlined in the slide,
he says, "Restored the child's
eyes to perfect health and sight."
Now, although Gale's account
is several centuries old,
it is analgous to our
current situation.
At present, there's an
urgent need for novel routes
to drug discovery due
to the emergence
of antibiotic resistant bacteria
and the lack of new drugs currently
in development to treat
antibiotic resistant infections.
The World Health Organization
stated in September,
2016 that antimicrobial resistance
is an increasingly serious threat
to global public health
that requires action
across all government
sectors and society.
In 2017, the CDC related a case
study of a woman in Nevada who died
of an infection that was resistant
to every known antimicrobial
in the United States.
Current estimates say that
around 700,000 people a year
around the world die of
antimicrobial resistant infections
and if no action is
taken, that estimate jumps
to 10 million people by 2050.
Now on your screen here
is a dramatic gesture
by image comics funded
by the Welcome Trust
to capture broad public attention
about this threat to health.
This is a comic book series
that envisions a post
antibiotic dystopia actually
in a much nearer future than 2050.
This one is set in 2036, in which
millions of people are dying
of antibiotic resistant infections.
Like Thomas Gale's remedy from an
old book, there are some historians
and scientists who
believe that the answer
to the antibiotic crisis may
be found in medical history
in combination with
modern technologies.
So in response to this
pressing global threat,
the Ancientbiotics team
was formed in 2014.
It is a truly interdisciplinary
and international team.
We are united by the
belief that novel routes
to drug discovery are necessary
as well as the conviction
that the past could
inform the future.
So along those lines, I'm going
to present some of the evidence
from the pilot study on an eye
remedy called Bald's Eyesalve,
and the following slides represent
data taken from the original paper,
which was published in in bio.
It's available online and represents
work done by [inaudible] Harrison,
Olive Roberts, Rebecca
Gabrilska [assumed spelling],
Kendra Rumball [assumed
spelling], Christina Lee
and Steve Digel [assumed spelling].
So here it is.
Bald's Eyesalve.
This is the recipe as it appears
in a book called Bald's Leechbook.
1000-year-old remedy book
held by the British library.
Now it is written in old English.
This is an Anglosaxon recipe.
But in modern English, as translated
by Christina Lee, it reads something
like make an eyesalve
against a wind.
Take equal amounts of an
allium species and garlic.
Pound them well together, take
equal amounts of wine and oxgall.
Mix that with the alliums.
Put this in a brass vessel.
Let the mixture stand for nine
nights in the brass vessel.
Wring through a cloth
and clarify it well.
Put in a horn and at night apply
it to the eye with a feather.
This is the best medicine.
Now, a wind in modern terms
could be translated as a sty
which is an infection
of the eyelash follicle.
And in modern terms,
the most common cause
of infection is the gram-positive
bacterium Staphylococcus aureus,
which also causes other severe
and persistent infections.
So what does the data show?
This is what the eyesalve
looks like.
And because the allium species
in the recipe is a little
bit ambiguous, a leek version
and an onion version of eyesalve
was made, and this is because leek
and onion, they both contain
antimicrobial flavonoids,
not found in garlic which is
already part of the recipe.
And onion also contains
an antimicrobial peptide.
So two versions of the
eyesalve were made.
One with leek, one with onion.
Preparations of individual
ingredients, versions of the recipes
with ingredients deleted and
then preparations of the recipe
to be tested before and after this
nine day activation period were
also prepared.
And it is noteworthy that after
these nine days the recipe
is self-sterilizing.
So first round of tests.
Bald's eyesalve kills Staph
aureus in planktonic culture,
and in synethetic wound
biofilm model.
In figure A, a control of sterile
distilled water which is represented
by the black line as
well as the two versions
of the recipe, onion and leek.
Onion is represented
by the red line.
And the leek is represented
by the blue line were added
to Staph aureus growing
in synthetic wound fluid
and then the optical density
of the culture was taken
during 18 hours of incubation.
You can very clearly see in this
image the difference in activity
between the control
and the two eyesalves.
In figure B, a control again
of sterile distilled water,
the two variance of
eyesalve onion and leek
and then each individual
ingredient on its own were added
to Staph aureus growing in a
synthetic wound biofilm model.
Here, the [inaudible]
denote treatments
that are significantly
different from the control.
And you'll note here
that on their own,
each individual ingredient
had no significant effect
on the reduction in bacteria.
However, the highlighted version
of the two full recipes did.
And this is a key idea, this
combination of ingredients.
This is where we seem to see this
potent anti-staphylococcal activity.
So along those lines, the
activity of Bald's eyesalve
against Staph aureus biofilms
requires several ingredients.
What is this image showing?
Here, there are the two
versions of the eyesalve,
the full recipe, onion and leek.
And then variance of the recipe
with ingredients deleted along
with an assessment
of their full partial
or no antimicrobial activity.
So here the gray bar is
showing the control again
of sterile distilled water.
The red bars are showing the full
and reduced versions
for the onion eyesalve.
The blue is showing full and reduced
versions for the leek eyesalve
and the green is showing
a variant of the recipe
with both onion and leek deleted.
So what to take away
from this image?
Deleting wine and garlic
from both variance
of the eyesalve totally eliminates
the bactericidal activity.
So it would seem that
the combination of wine,
garlic and allium species
are crucial
for the full efficacy
of Bald's eyesalve.
Also, when onion is used instead of
leek, oxgall seems to be necessary.
In both cases, brass is dispensable.
So because of this
combination of ingredients,
we also look to the nine
day activation period
to see perhaps this recipe.
There might be some
methodology to it.
Here, again a control of sterile
distilled water and the two variance
of eyesalve were added
to Staph aureus growing
in a wound biofilm model
immediately after preparation.
And the bactericidal
activity was quantified.
Those results are shown
by the shaded bars.
The experiment was repeated after
the nine day activation period,
and that activity is
shown by the open bars.
You can clearly see the
difference in activity
over this nine day waiting period
between the shaded and open bars
in both variance of the eyesalve.
So what I just talked about is in
vitro results against Staph aureus.
Because it performed so well
in these tests, it was decided
that it should be tested in vivo
against a resistant pathogen.
Tissue from wound samples of mice
infected with MRSA were submerged
in a control of sterile saline,
vancomycin which is a
clinical last line antibiotic
and then the two variance
of the eyesalve.
Again, here asterisks
denote treatments
which are significantly
different from the control.
You will note that the last line
antibiotic vancomycin produced no
significant reduction
in viable bacteria.
However, both of the eyesalves did.
So it would seem that Bald's
eyesalve shows potential
as an anti-staphylococcal agent
not only in vitro but in vivo
against a resistant pathogen.
So what about against
nonbacterial parasites?
So Leishmaniasis for those who
might not be familiar with it,
it's a protozoan parasite infection.
It is caused by the bite
of female sand flies.
It has a major problem in
warm parts of the world,
and it's becoming an
increasing problem
with large scale displacement
of humans
and people living in refugee camps.
And what it does is it causes
very unpleasant lesions
which are then susceptible to
infection by secondary bodies
like Staph aureus and other species.
So this work is -- has
been done by Lee Haines
of the Liverpool School
of Tropical Medicine.
She's pictured here in the slide
taking a swab from a patient,
and the other image that you see
is a [inaudible] stained slide
of human macrophage cells.
The gray area are red blood cells.
The purple area is the macrophage.
The large dark purple area
is the nucleus and then
if you look closely you
can see dark purple specks.
Those are the Leishmaniasis
parasites,
and what they do is they
evade human immunity by hiding
within human macrophages.
They rupture the cell and then
invade other macrophage cells.
Oh, word of warning
before the next slide.
I know we are not all
scientists here.
So I'm about to show a somewhat
graphic image of a patient
with pretty severely infected
Leishmaniasis lesions.
So if you find that disturbing,
perhaps proceed with caution.
Here we go.
So you can see the immense
pain and suffering that results
from these lesions,
particularly when Staph aureus
or another bacteria
begins an infection.
And especially for people
who have been displaced,
people living in refugee camps
without adequate access
to medical care.
And once these lesions heal,
they often cause scarring,
pretty significant
scarring on the face,
and that can lead to social stigma.
It can lead to bullying and
depression, a loss of education
if children then don't want to
go to school and in some parts
of the world for young girls,
it can lead to a loss
of marriage prospects.
So if you contract this and
you live in a part of the world
with stable access to medical
care, you could receive treatment
by cryotherapy or thermal therapy.
But typically the drug most usually
used is called pentastem [ph],
and this is injected either
intramuscularly or intralesionally.
And depending on the
type of species,
Leishmaniasis species
causing the problem,
the treatment can be quite
painful, quite long up to 18 months
in duration for some people.
And you can imagine this is quite a
disheartening prospect for patients.
Some people will refuse
the injections and try
and treat it themselves by
burning the lesions with cigarettes
or with fire, trying
to cut the lesion,
which clearly is not going
to help the situation.
So what does this have
to do with eyesalve?
In the assay shown here, live
parasites were exposed to dilutions
of both versions of the eyesalve.
Both onion and leek
over a two day period.
After the two day period,
a dye was added in order
to measure metabolic
activity to measure
if the parasites are alive or dead.
When parasites are alive,
the dye turns bright pink.
When parasites are dead,
the dye stays dark blue.
And you can see where
it says onion variant
and leek variant the
dye is dark blue.
It's clearly dead parasites.
Now, this is quite
an exciting result
but it's also a preliminary result.
Right now the eyesalve is being
tested on human macrophage cells
in order to ascertain its
effects on human cells.
So it has to be determined that the
eyesalve is harmless to human cells
but maintains its toxicity against
the parasites living within them.
To summarize this evidence, but I
went through a little bit quickly,
all of the ingredients are necessary
for the eyesalve to work except
for potentially the brass elements.
Also necessary is this
nine day activation period.
This idea of a combination
of ingredients
in premodern medicine
is quite a key idea.
Why might this be working?
It could be that the
antimicrobial activity
of the individual ingredients
on their own is combining
to make the eyesalve greater
than some of its parts.
It could be that bacteria
is being attacked
on multiple different fronts.
It also could be that this nine day
activation period perhaps a novel
compound is being formed
over this time.
These are questions to be
answered by future research
and that is where it is heading.
Another key point.
The recipe is highly
reproducible, which is significant.
As of right now, six people
have made a couple dozen batches
of the eyesalve using fresh
ingredients each time and all
of them work equally well
against Staph aureus.
As I alluded to, current tests
are being done on Bald's eyesalve
for its effects on human
cells, and that will determine
where it goes from there.
Also, an analysis of how it's
working, why is it effective?
Is there a novel compound
being formed?
Why this cocktail of ingredients?
And switching gears a little bit,
you'll recall from the beginning
I related story of Thomas Gale
and the Lylye of Medicynes.
So this is the text that I
produced the first edition
of for my doctoral work,
and it contains a wealth
of pharmaceutical information
so from that text,
we're doing something
a little bit different.
There is a chapter
on weakness of sight,
and within that chapter there
are different remedies for loss
of eyesight, debilitating vision,
problems related to old age.
And so there's a recipe
that in translation
from the middle English it says God
has not given us a better recipe
than this one.
It makes even old men to read
tiny letters without aid.
And so that is quite the promise.
And so we decided to test that
one against macular degeneration.
That is an ongoing test
at the moment being run
by Lisa Charkarubarti [assumed
spelling] at the University
of Nottingham but we do hope to have
some results for that by the summer.
Another interesting ingredient from
the Lylye of Medicynes is Plantago.
Now, this may be an unfamiliar herb
but has a long and exalted history
in medical history being used
by Greek authorities all the way
up to the present day even
in [inaudible] practices.
One scholar has termed it nature's
Band-Aid because it's so effective
at wound healing, insect stings
and also infection prevention,
which is also part of
the recovery process.
So right now we're -- this
is in theoretical stage,
but we hope to look at Plantago
major, Plantago [inaudible]
for effects in wound healing
and infection prevention.
Also, you'll see on her a
cold and flu preventative.
This is a drink that I have made
based on inspired by Dr. Bernard
of the Lyly of Medicynes
and something I've been taking
myself for about three years.
Anecdotal evidence is very strong.
Of course, I'm not going to give
you the recipe because I cannot say
to test this on yourself, definitely
not and do not test Bald's eyesalve.
But that one because of this
particular cocktail of ingredience
and the anecdotal evidence I
think we can make a strong case
for this one.
We're also going to be testing
that later in the summer.
And maybe develop something
from that.
So of all of these ongoing
interesting exciting projects,
for the remainder of our
time, I'd like to focus
in on a recipe database and a
pilot study we're going to do
on data mining, the
Lyly of Medicynes.
Just a little bit more
about this text.
There it is.
at the Bodleian Library.
It is the only extant middle
English translation of Bernard
of Gordon's Lilium medicinae,
which was originally written
in [inaudible] and
completed in 1305.
Then the middle English translation
came about a century later.
Latest known printing
that we know of happened
in the late -- very
late 17th century.
So you can see from the date span
it was a hugely significant text
through the medieval period
through the Renaissance
and into the early modern period.
And like I said, it contains a lot
of very interesting
pharmaceutical information.
That was probably the most
significant aspect of it.
So it makes a very good text
to base this pilot study on.
What I've done, the lyly
contains around 6000 references
to particular ingredients, 360 very
specific recipes which represents
over 110 disease conditions.
And I put these into a database
that we hope to analyze looking
for nonrandom co-occurrences
of these ingredient cocktails.
All of these recipes that
I've talked to you about now,
Bald's eyesalve, the remedy
for macular degeneration,
Plantago [inaudible] even
the cold and flu remedy,
they've all been hand selected by
researchers using a prior knowledge.
It's quite time consuming.
And we're wondering if
there might be a faster way
to identify these cocktails
of ingredients
to inform laboratory testing and
eliminate this kind of hunting
and picking method
through medieval text.
So that is what we're
aiming for in the future,
and this pilot study
has already commenced
and hopefully will again summer --
summer is going to be a big time --
we're looking to have some
data out in the summer.
And not only would such a
project inform laboratory research
which has implications for new drug
discovery, but it could go some way
to answering some of the
questions I posed at the beginning
of this talk regarding
the methodology
of medieval medical practitioners.
Often it's viewed as when
you see the long list
of ingredients contained
in medieval text,
you think they were just trying
anything they could without thought,
but it would seem there is more
methodology to these practices.
Even in the Lyly of Medicynes,
he says if you don't know
what to do, try this remedy.
See what happens.
But when you look at
recipes like Bald's eyesalve,
meticulously put together even
down to the amount of time it takes
to produce this bactericidal
activity.
So we hope to explore that as well.
This is a little bit of a whirl wind
tour through two years of research,
and I would like to close with
just a few concluding thoughts
on the great virtue
of interdisciplinary
and international collaboration.
The arts and sciences
are often presented
as these diametric opposites.
But hopefully, in this talk I've
shown how much we need each other
and that when we work together we
can produce results that are greater
than the sum of our
individual parts.
And clearly not every
collaboration is created equally.
And it requires very
specific traits to be part
of such a well integrated
and unified team.
Turning historical medical text
into new drug discovery requires
very close working relationships
with very different disciplines,
excellent communication skills,
open-mindedness, accessibility
and discoverability of data
and knowledge exchange across such
a wide variety of disciplines.
In our team, we have
paracytologists, medievalists,
historians, climate historians,
microbiologists, medicinal chemists,
data scientists, mathematicians,
spreading the disciplines
and across countries.
We might summarize that by saying
a global problem requires a
global mindset.
And with further research in this
spirit, it may be possible to show
that the Ancientbiotics of
yesterday have real implications
for the antibiotics of today.
And I know we're a
little bit earlier,
but that leaves lots
of time for questions.
Thank you so much for
your attention.
Very happy to discuss [inaudible].
[ Applause ]
Yes.
>> So if Bald's eyesalve worked
well with some of these conditions,
why do you think it
fell into disuse?
>> Erin Connelly: Disuse
in medical history?
>> Disuse -- presumably at some
point people stopped using it
because even the woman that we're
told about in the little story had
to go look it up in an old
book because the doctors
at the time had forgotten about it.
>> Erin Connelly: Oh, yes.
Sorry. Thomas Gale's remedy,
that was a different eye
remedy to Bald's eyesalve.
So and for those who might
not have heard the question,
she was asking why did
Bald's eyesalve fall
out of use if it was so effective?
So Thomas Gale used a different
eye remedy, but yeah at some point,
we did stop using this
combination of ingredients to put
on our infections on our eye.
So there could be a couple
of different answers to that.
One is the view of the
medieval period as a dark age.
Other generations looking back and
saying no, we are far more advanced.
There's nothing we
can learn from that.
There has been pretty permanent
outlook for a long bit of history.
Second, all bacteria will develop
methods to the antibiotics,
whatever form it is, being --
that they're being exposed to.
So they will develop
resistance to them.
So it's possible that
Bald's eyesalve
and other treatments being
constantly used bacteria,
constantly being exposed to
that form of an antibiotic
that they developed
resistance to it.
So it didn't work.
We've not used it for all this time.
Maybe that's one of the reasons
why it's showing such efficacy.
And if nothing else,
perhaps something like it.
This is speculating
far into the future.
If it was to become something
that was useful as an antibiotic,
you know eventually bacteria
would become resistant to that.
But it could buy some time.
I mean, thinking about that
statistic, which was put forth
by the AMR review,
Antimicrobial Review 2014.
700,000 people currently dying, up
to ten million estimated by 2050.
I mean, it could buy some time
and then there could be a
return to other antibiotics.
So -- and part of that is
the antibiotic revolution.
We live in very unique times
with laboratory science
and although it is true that a lot
of our compounds that we would see
as pharmaceuticals are
derived from natural sources.
It often doesn't come
to us in that way.
So there is a connection there
of using nature to
find new antibiotics.
Did I answer -- yes.
[ Inaudible ]
Yes. No. That's a very
good question actually.
I brought the paper with me because
I want to get it exactly right.
It's actually where
the wine was sourced,
it was an English white wine
from an area of the country
when old English monastery
used to own the vineyard there.
So it was as close as we could get.
Yes. Here we go.
Organic English white whine produced
by a vineyard situated seven miles
from the village of
Panbora [ph] and Somerset.
A charter of 8956 tells us
that the Anglosaxon monastery
of St. Mary's Abbey in
[inaudible] held hand rights
to a vineyard at Panbora.
So we also with the honey as well
because obvoiusly this is
not an exercise in trying
to replicate the medieval past,
which we would argue is
probably somewhat futile
because we cannot replicate
those conditions whatsoever.
Our purposes are totally different,
but we did try and get close
to ingredients like the wine.
The honey was sourced from
[inaudible], a lady in Surrey
who had recreated a medieval garden
with medicinal herbs and plants
and bees nearby were
pollinating those plants.
So that's where we
obtained the honey from.
And just for some continuity.
Yes.
>> I have two questions.
One was in your studies did
you find that the formula --
Bald's formula -- was
bactericidal or bacteriostatic?
And the other one is I'm kind of
mystified by the nine day shelf life
or the -- actually I'd like
to know the shelf life.
Once it reached the nine day,
was it potent on nine days?
Which was probably just
serendipitously discovered.
>> Erin Connelly: Trial
and error, yeah.
>> And how long was it
good for thereafter?
>> Erin Connelly: Yes.
So I'm not a Ph.D. microbiologist.
But I'm going to answer this.
I will recommend that you
look to the paper as well
and anything I don't
answer, contact Fred Harrison
or Steve Digel whose email
addresses are on the paper.
And they'll be happy to answer it.
So the question for those who
didn't hear it was Bald's eyesalve
bacteriocidal or bacteristatic?
And the answer that's coming to me
from the paper is bacteriocidal,
and in the results as well it was
found the word design has actually
been used in reference
to this recipe.
In that it treats the
infection that it was designed
to treat almost in a targeted way.
And the eyesalve has been
tested against other pathogens
such as K pneumoniae and E. coli and
Enterobacter and things like that.
And the activity is different
so it's not like dumping bleach
on something where it
just kills everything.
It seems to be specifically targeted
to what it was made to treat,
which is very interesting and worthy
of more research and
that is ongoing.
And then the other question was --
was the eyesalve good for
the entire nine day period?
What was its activity
through that period
and how long does it stay good?
That is actually being
looked at at the moment.
There have been some old samples of
the eyesalve that are being tested.
I was actually just speaking
to the microbiologist
who performed this work,
and she had some old samples
that they're testing.
So I'm not sure about the terminal
dates, how long it stays good.
I believe it has been tested, but
I can't give it's bad after 30 days
or it becomes toxic
after this period.
[ Inaudible ]
At room temperature.
And that was a consideration
in running this test.
There were a lot of decisoins that
had to be made and it was decided
to keep the eyesalve in the
refrigerator because in the building
where the lab was, the
heat comes on and off.
And it was decided that
fluctuations in temperature
like that would be more
unrealistic then keeping it
at a steady temperature because
often in other medieval recipes --
actually the one with
macular degeneration,
one of the instructions says
make it as hot as a hen's nest
when she's sitting on a nest.
What temperature would that be?
So I'll find a hen or -- so
that is during the winter.
If it's being made during the
summer, the recipe is to sit
in a cool dark shadow so it's what
they had in their environment,
but they're looking for
a steady temperature.
With the hen, steady temperature,
dark shadow, steady temperature.
So that's why we chose
refrigeration.
Yes.
>> You mentioned that one of the
things that you discovered is
that the Bald's eyesalve recipe for
instance is highly reproducible.
You can make the same
thing again and again.
Is there any intent to try making
the recipe with modern wine
and honey since those two
ingredients seem to be
so much limited in availability?
>> Erin Connelly: Well, we could
say it was made with modern wine
and honey because we don't
really have access --
all of these ingredients are
modern in the sense that --
sorry, for those who
didn't hear the question,
it was has there been any
attempt to perhaps change the wine
and honey other then the ones
that we used in the original test?
Yeah, okay.
No. It's -- well with the
six who have reproduced it,
I'm not entirely sure if they
used the exact same sources,
although I think they did
because they were trying
to replicate it exactly.
I know that in the recipe
that I made with the cold
and flu preventative I changed
the honey multiple times,
and we still need to
test this, but I will say
that Manuka honey would be
worth trialing in one of these
because it is -- it has the highest
antimicrobial content of any honey.
And it's what I use in my recipe.
Maybe it's a placebo effect
because I really believe in it.
But that waits to be seen.
Yeah, because often medieval recipes
-- even with vinegar and with wine,
they'll say make it a weak
wine, make it a strong vinegar.
Sometimes they don't give a lot
of guidance to what that means.
Obviously with a weak wine, you
would think perhaps it's newly made
or they're diluting it with
water or some other ingredients.
But yeah, did that answer?
>> To a certain extent, but one of
the things that I was more curious
about is if these recipes
prove to be efficacious,
then in order to ramp up
production you have to be able
to source ingredients on a
mass scale, and it seems to me
that a small vineyard [inaudible]
a local bee keeper aren't going
to serve for mass production.
>> Erin Connelly: No, no.
In that case, we would have
to find a different source.
And I would -- I would say Manuka
is one of the best that we could do.
But no, that tiny vineyard
and the poor bee keeper,
no for worldwide production, but
of course we're not there yet.
That was mainly done for the sake
of the pilot study and to keep it
as close to the Anglosaxon
source as possible.
And also because no one
expected it to be so effective.
It was what we could call
a Friday afternoon project.
Everybody did this
in their spare time,
kind of still doing it that way.
And it was really quite shocking
when these results came back
and right now the recipe --
we're looking into the mechanism
and action and that kind of thing.
But its effects on human
cells need to be looked
at first before we
look at anything else.
Thank you.
Yes.
>> Someone online asks if
your team had any thoughts
about substituting the Oxgall?
>> Erin Connelly: No.
Did they mention what they thought
it might be substituted with?
>> They mentioned the
possible objectives would be
for vegans or those with allergies.
>> Erin Connelly: Oh, right.
The thought with Oxgall
because -- here I'll show you.
That is a good point.
So in this graph, you
see with the leek version
of the eyesalve, Oxgall
is not necessary.
With the onion version, there's only
partial activity when it's limited.
So it's an ingredient sort of like
brass that could be dispensable.
The eyesalve is not showing
its full activity in --
with that ingredient present.
So in the future, it could
be something to look at.
I'm not sure what we
would substitute it
with because [inaudible] bile.
Bile can act as a surfactant.
Yes.
>> Are you getting any
interesting responses
from the medical biology
research community [inaudible]?
>> Eric Connelly: Yes, actually --
so the question was have there
been any interesting responses
from the microbiologist community?
And yes, actually in 2015 when this
data was announced and published,
it actually attracted
worldwide attention.
And the two leads of the project,
Christina Lee who's
the Anglosaxonist
who translated the recipe and
Fraya [assumed spelling] Harrison
who led the microbiology work,
they did a lot of interviews
with worldwide news outlets and the
paper has quite high impact rating,
and it kind of went all over the
world for a time and responses
from microbiologists unless there's
something I don't know about,
they've been very positive.
And I think people are quite
inspired not just by this research
but by lots of research going on
with neutraceuticals and looking
to the past for inspiration.
There's even a team in Sweden I
believe that just produced mead,
viking mead which is
highly antibacterial.
They produced it for sale.
So you can buy it if you like.
And for the person with the honey
question, they did use honey in it.
It'd be interesting to
note what honey they used
because I'm not sure.
I just saw that data last night.
So I think it's a -- we're right
on the verge perhaps of something.
But yeah, responses
have been very positive
and I think people are quite
excited about this research
and the potential it has.
Of course, this is very preliminary.
It has to be tested on human cells
before anymore progress can be made.
Yeah.
>> Fenella France:
Do you have any further
questions for Erin?
I do have to say that in New Zealand
we use Manuka honey in all kinds
of everything [inaudible].
>> Erin Connelly: When you walked
in, I thought Manuka, New Zealand.
But yes, thank you all very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.
This has been a presentation
of the Library
of Congress, visit us at loc.gov.